إذا كنت تعتقد أنك على وجه الخصوص
لن تتأثر بمجاملة ، فأنت بعمق
أنت مخطئ إنسانيًا في ما سيحدث
الدهون في الردهة
لأكثر من 70 علاجًا ، من السهل تشغيلها
ستكون هناك 10 أضعاف تلك الحرب قريبًا لم نعطِها
برودة عليا الثناء. أو اضغط علي
حذف أي شكاوى حول فيلم lightfit
اطلاق النار أوكرانيا الانتباه إلى هذا
طريق المحكمة
مليون دولار
أنا في بداية فبراير عندما كل هذا
كان في الصين كان لي أن يكون
أنا لست مهتمًا على الإطلاق
يتبع
بدا لي أن هذه هي الصين من ناحية أخرى
نهاية العالم المنسكب ستصل إلينا و
لهذا أصبحت مدونًا لأن
مررت به ولا أريد ذلك
كرر شخص ما طريقي وإذا استطعت
مساعدة شخص ما على عدم ارتكاب أخطائي
هذا هو الشيء الأكثر أهمية هناك إيرينا الصغير
مجموعة fi والمراحيض أو تقويم الفيلم
بانج باه ي هولين مونتاج lesika رأي خارج
ملحق دور تقارب shubat هي الأولى
التراخي في أذربيجان أو على
شخص ما إلى مخطط على العقل أربات أوليا
من هناك هي أنت ونخبة السكين الروسية
دكان البيدق دائري كوبي أمين الصندوق
فالنتينا فومينا حول سنوات السيارات أوليا
der or 100 years article shkas and mass لها
مفتاح أن نكون نحن من أجل طلب السم
ديرما سلاك كتان كتان tm
من لم يره يمكنه أن يقول ما هو عليه
لا تقلق ، سوف يمر كل شيء ، أنا فقط
أتمنى للجميع أن يكون ذلك
شكل خفيف ولكن إذا كان هذا شكل حاد
كيف استراح الكلاب المرحلة مخيفة و
كنت على لسانك والآن هو يتنفس 45
دقائق تفهم أن هذا منتفخ
لا يمكننا قول أي شيء بعينه
الأزرق في يد زرقاء بالفعل بسبب
أنه لا يوجد أكسجين في الدم
تم عمل فتحات Aterina Marie بينما غادرت
Russo Rune Lee Alimony إلى زيادة حجم الصوت
سوء مثل هذه الكعكة 1 في بعض الأحيان بالترتيب
أورثيا
bailando نفس المنحدر الكبريتات 2 و
وضع مقال ولكن هي رابطة إيما على
أصعب جزء هو طفلي و
تريد أن تعانقني قبلة تكبب
بالنسبة لي وها هي
مرحباً ، نحن على بعد حوالي متر
من بعضنا البعض لذلك طلبت ذلك
إذا اضطررت إلى العمل ، فاتركني
مستشفى سأعمل 24 ساعة في اليوم
لا ترسلني وحدي وبعد ذلك نحن
تحول الجميع إلى جهاز التحكم عن بعد هذا لي
لا أحد قريب مني أقوى
تناسب القطط لدينا جميع الابتعاد
زوجي في المسافة يهرب هنا
من فضلك لا توجد سجلات
الاتصالات وهذا واحد هذا الخزان أنا
أعود إلى المنزل وأول شيء أفعله هو التصوير
أجمع الأحذية
لأن الزوج لا يحتاج إلى شيء
الحالة لا تنظف ، لا أحتاجها على الفور
خذ خزانة ، ثم أفعلها على الفور هكذا
إلى مجموعتنا ثم ارتداء الملابس على الفور
قناع لأنني سأزيل القناع عن السيارة
ثم ترتدي بيرو قناعًا في المنزل تأخذك بعيدًا
فيروس كورونا لن ينقذ لكنه سينقذ
المحيط
انتهى الأمر حذف إيلما عطر مخيف شانيل
سيضع المحيط بيت القبر ولحم الشركة
الدنمارك
المكسرات و jive الكربون النبالة لهذا الغرض
كاتالين تريد مع صوفيا و
glocken and power أصلي لوزارة المالية فقط التل
hajus هذه الكرة الملايين من scholes
أختار خلفية البعوض
مجرد سؤال بسيط للغاية للشراء
الناس الذين حفرة حفاضات الأيدي سوف تصبح حمراء
دبابات آسوس حتى معطف أسود الشق
يقف أوليمبوس بالقرب من شخص مثل ذبابة سمكة بئر
الصعود بعيدًا عن الأنظار حان الوقت لوضع الأغاني
الجهاز التنفسي
أنا الشعب لأعرض جهود الصالة الأولى للإثنين
malinois قيعان لنا للأطفال
نوع ديمينتا دقيق لعالم الأفلام
حرق بنك مدخراتهم لليهود
بدون عواطف سأحاول شرح ماذا
الآن ما يحدث لي شخصيا
مستاء للغاية من أن يكون أوليسوف سيئًا
يتم سحب فيكتوريا شوتوفا من الدهون مرة أخرى
وصدرية القمر قبل فيديو أبريل
انتقل الآن إلى فيروس كورونا متحورًا مثل
يخبروننا جميعًا بجرأة وبسبب حقيقة أنه
بدأ على نطاق واسع يمرض الناس من الوسط
العمر والمرض بشدة
ولذلك أتوسل إليكم أن تدرجوا و
أخيرًا يتجه أقل إلى
صغيرة
أخيرًا أدر رأسك واجلس
المنزل في ملح كبار السن في المنزل
اجلس بنفسك ثم سأذهب هذا الصباح
لا استطيع الذهاب الى العمل
يقود سيارته إلى العمل وهي أيضًا اصطدمت بالحامل
الاختناقات المرورية ولكن الكثير من الناس يمشون
ارتدِ قناعًا ارتدِ قفازات واجلس
في المنزل أنا شخص محتمل
يتحمل فيروس كورونا أعود إلى المنزل
لدي شقة فارغة ولدي ثلاثة أطفال
أنا شخص مقرب مني قبل كل شيء
تفرق لأنني أفهم ل
بعض لكن
تهديد مباشر ولكن ما أعمل من أجله
السرعة أعود للمنزل من الهدوء إلى
شقتي فارغة في شقتي وأنا
أستطيع ولكن كيف سأعطي الإيطاليين يأتي
منزل إطلاق شقة النفط لأن
مات كل ما ستدعونا نحن
سوف نأتي ولكن ليس حقيقة ما بالضبط
ما يكفي من الأكسجين لتشغيله
فيديو فيكتوريا وأرسل لهم حجة غياب
العمارة فقط سوريا لدينا k2 ليتا وداريا
نغمة ألفا النشطة لذا فكتوريا أقرب
لافتة ecaille
أعطي جميع الرسائل الخاصة التي
تعال لأن الناس يكتبون كثيرًا
الناس يكتبون نوبات الغضب ثم أنا لا
أعرف ماذا أفعل لا أعرف ماذا أفعل
ليس الطفل موجودًا مع جدته من أجل أي شيء
مع جهاز درجة الحرارة الخاص به يكمن في المنزل و
المقاتلين هناك تعرف سيارة الإسعاف وسيأخذونها
تطلق قطرة في المحيط من حيث
على نطاق وطني ، بينما أنا
أعتقد أن الكأس الخاصة بي ليست كذلك
طنانة والكلمات لا أعتقد ذلك
إلى واجب المواطن كطبيب
موظف للإجابة على هذه الأسئلة و
الجانب النفسي قبل الاستفزاز
أصبح العمل أصعب بكثير هنا هنا
مرات ويمكن أن يكون نفس المقدار
يدعو الى خروج الكتائب ولكن في نفس الوقت كله
الجميع متعب جدا
نفسية عاطفية
مكون لأنه ، حسنًا ، كثيرًا
هناك عندما ينهار الناس الذعر و
تحتاج إلى تهدئته إلى هذا الحد
يأخذ الكثير من الطاقة
موعد الأفلام قبل فترة سماح الفروض المدرسية
وقحة axor لي الكيمياء شبم شخص ما
مكان الغداء التوت أو بلا من أعتقد ذلك
أنت مميز أو مميز هو أنك لست كذلك
اللمسات شركات بعد أن كانت عميقة
مخدوع
عاجلاً أم آجلاً ستؤثر على الجميع وعليك
مجرد رسام قلب ابق في المنزل
مراقبة الانضباط الذاتي والعزلة الذاتية
الكثير من الطاقم الطبي
الآن هم مرضى جدا
يخاطرون بحياتهم بصحتهم
ابق في المنزل
[موسيقى]
أعطيت ألفي
الأوروبيون الأثرياء بزيت نيويورك ليسوا كلهم
باهر
veronika dubrovskaya ثم bebutov المشرف
تذوب هذا الفيلم عزيزي
على الغضب
[موسيقى]
مرة اخري
مقروص
انفصال عن بلقيس وجراحة نوفل
أماكن Gödel لأوقات البرد وكورونا
اتحاد الأسماك فشل هذا كما لو
دوبي أوديسيت إلى 1 مايونيز هو كذلك
أو رحلة إلزامية
ش و 0 على أساس النماذج ماذا سيبقى
على مستوى
سارس أي السنة الثالثة
والتي حملت ضربة قاصمة إلى الجنوب
نظام صحي لزج ولكن ليس
الأنظمة الموزعة التي كانت عليه
شكل مميت شديد الخطورة وهنا
نرى أن الفيروس قد تطور أي
يتم نقل الكثير من الأفكار بسهولة و
عمليا لا تقل أو لا تقل
أي أعراض طفيفة وبدقة
لذلك هذا البروتين القطران شخص ما
شارب التطور البدني على الميدان
وذهب الشويرا المركيز إلينا وأصبح كذلك
حصة الفيلم
أنفاق العملات وعلى طول الفيتامينات وأشياء
تجدها العروس
عند الوصول مقروصًا في زاوية كل منهما
المستشفى الآن
يوم واحد قد هلكت على نفسك
سنة إذا 30
الشاذ والطيور عندما يكون هناك ليوم واحد
اتضح 15 17 19
قدرة مورغان محدودة نعم أعتقد
وهو أكثر إنسانية من هذا
الدهون تخرج فقط أي المال نجار الجسم
وضعت في الممر ولكن حسب سمعنا
ثلاجة
[تصفيق]
اترك مواقع الهكر كابيلا تنتهي
يتحدث
[موسيقى]
أثناء القصف
ينامون
عندما يكون بعض من كلتا الرئتين
ترك لمدة عشرة أو خمسة عشر شمسا
أي حكومة حددت الأمة
يساعد بشكل خاص حول مخيف من
هذا كل شيء ، العجز والإلهاء
نحاول أن نفهم القليل ونحن نعرف ما لا
فهم ذلك بقناعة عميقة
مراحل مختلفة
سيكون هناك karsts مختلفة في أنها تعمل
بدأت بدون احتمالية
معنى إلى وسط قطع الكسندر
شريحة لحم الخاصرة teimuri الكازاخستانية نيويورك
أصلي فرهود راضية ميا
أنا متعب ، أريد أن أنام ، وكل شيء معي
أنهى ما يقرب من 13 ساعة في الورديات مثل
حتى أنني جلست لأكون في الثالثة
موعد الرسوم المتحركة كتلة كبيرة 10 سريرا
والدول التي عاشت لها الحلمات
التي تتطلب الانضباط من الرعاية و
تغييرات متكررة في المعلمة
كل من التهوية والأدوية
طيور النورس تبكي لحظات استقبال أخرى
 قسم، أقسام
كل الالتهابات لم تأخذ 10 أعلى s
الحقن ، أي الآن يضعون 100
يمكن للمرضى أن ينظروا بسرعة
تقرر ما إذا كان بحاجة إلى مزيد من المساعدة
هناك على أسس لك بالقول الواردة
تُترك بمفردها وعند المشي
انا انظر
عدد كبير من المرضى الأكبر سنًا
العلاج ، أي 140 شخصًا في نافذة اليوم
alexander كابل عليك والأفلام مع.
بدون لقب بدأ أنبوب قاتل
عبس المردان
داء العثة وكبار السن الأعرج
حصلت على روبن على الماء أغسطس ووليام
شارع ضعيف من الورود
الانتباه الحد الأدنى من السعال و
الحد الأدنى من الانزعاج
ونفسا عميقا من الصلب وكان القديس
على غرار آلام الظهر
آلام العضلات بسبب وأنا أفعل الآن
أنا أؤمن أنك كذلك
الحصانة التي وفقا لك سوف تمرض
تفعل أكثر قليلاً من إيكاري الذي لا يفعل
فهم يؤلمون ذلك دعنا نقول على وجه اليقين
كما تعلم ، كنت مريضا بدا أمس من قبل
عمل تذكاري فقط اذهب إلى أي مكان
الدوس على المواقع الطبية فقط
العمال الدائمة وبالطبع جدا جدا
[موسيقى]
سأقتل أمي الحمضية
دعونا
يوجد اليوم أكثر من 70 طبيباً
مات في إيطاليا أنت تفهم بي
زملائي ، أنا فقط أتخيل
الآن إذا عملت في العناية المركزة
الطبيب سيفعل لزملائي بالطبع
لن أقول إنني عالجته بشكل أفضل
من الآخرين ، لكني كنت سأفعل ذلك
عليك أن تفهم أن هذا زميل ولكن
لكنه إنسان طبيعي و
حتى لو لم يتم إنقاذهم
ثم هنا ولكن بالنسبة لشخص ما هنا هو الجرس
ستنجح ، وسيفهم شخص ما ما يحدث
أن هذه ليست مزحة بدون نوافذ و ferb
لمدة عشر كلمات وأنا أولغا لحظة وا لا سي
قبل
على النبيونة الكبح قليلا كبيرة و
كان بيت الدعارة لا يحتوي على لتر من الجليد بشكل خاص
لذلك لا تدفع الشجرة ثم المريء بعد ذلك
وفقا للمادة سائق بول نغمة
يحترم المسافة و
نعم ويظهر ركله مع و
أنا واسع البوم وأبيض سلوبوديان 2
لوميناكلي أو كمامة
[موسيقى]
طية صدر السترة لول
أنت خادم ممتاز
ليونة عزيزي تريد جولات التسوق
[موسيقى]
منذ أسابيع
لكن كل يوم هناك فرصة
كسب رؤساء الدعاوى الخطرة
جمع المال و
تم شراؤها. هذه لحظة صغيرة لكنها ليست كذلك
كما لو كان في نشاط مشترك هناك مع المثل الأعلى
الحماية دون تقديم التباهي
إذا لم يكن ذلك كافيًا
أحد أصدقائي الذين
رجل الأعمال الذي لديه مصنعه الخاص هناك وهو
أرسلوا له هذه الأقنعة من الصين
لقد جلب الكثير إلى مستشفانا
ثم ذهبت إلى مستشفى كبير في
كما سمعت مستعمرة هناك
هذا ما يفتقرون إليه من الأقنعة مرة أخرى
دعاه وأرسل هؤلاء
أقنعة يوم واحد في المنزل من حجم على واينز
إنها شريرة تدمر الطائرة لتسرع
حتى باريس ليليث المؤلم نصف كوب
أنف واحد على الإطلاق يسلبه
ما هو هناك كل شيء ما يجب القيام به ما لم تذهب سدى و
لم تفعل الآن بداية من هذا القبيل أن لا
فعل قبل عشرة أيام خرج الناس
نعم يساعد بالتأكيد عموم ضجيجا
لا يهم أخلاقيا
القيم العامة في العالم في رأيي
تبادلوا فقط سلموا
بدأ الجانب الأيمن من الناس في الارتباط
بشكل مختلف حتى على مستوى مدينة فيبورغ
يتصلون ويسألون
هل يمكنك أن تعطينا بعض النصائح
الهاتف وحتى لا نسحب لك ذلك
لا تتعب مرات أكثر ، وهذا هو ، ربما
يكون جائحة نشأ لأنه أقلها
يجب أن أتعلم شيئًا كبيرًا
الحساب لا يهتم بما هو وزننا ، ولكن
للأسف هذه هي اللهجة
حول العالم ليوم واحد لمدة عام ولمدة
الحالة عندما تضيع بحتة
الإنسان يقدرني بالطبع
الآن نحن خائفون من القيم الإنسانية
يموت صديق دعم الاتصال و
الأقارب والأصدقاء وسألهم عما إذا كانوا مرضى
ما إذا كان هناك اكتئاب سريري يرجع إلى حقيقة
ما يحدث لدينا قرض ضخم
المنزل قمنا ببناء منزل كبير الآن
راتبي تقريبا
يذهب إلى القرض وعشنا على حقيقة ذلك
حصل على مطعمه وحانة
أغلق الأسبوع الرابع بشكل طبيعي
تعال جميع الضرائب التي لم يلغها أحد
يجب دفع ضرائب الأنوار التي تحتاجها المياه
ادفع الآن أنا أفعل الورق المقوى
الكثير من الوقت بشكل إيجابي
نفذت من قبل الأطفال معهم قط
لعبت لي الطبخ المجاني
غذاء
أنا لا أشارك في هذا على الإطلاق
مثل زوجي وابني
أريكة تعقيم الترتيبات الممكنة
كيف ستعمل مع الأجسام المضادة
أي أن المرضى يمنحهم القوة
يمكن لهؤلاء الأشخاص العودة إلى القناة
لأن تدرك يا لها من ضربة كبيرة
على الاقتصاد الآن في جميع أنحاء العالم
هذا هو ، أعتقد أننا سنفعل
قريبا عمل النظام الحيوي
طلب جواز سفر 100 أو أي شكل آخر
سيكون هناك زهور ونبيذ أو أي شيء آخر و
سيتم وصف ما هو عليه
تغلبت على المنافسة بسبب
وإلا سيكون وباء
تواصل ولكن على الأقل موهبة عام
متى سيصل اللقاح
[موسيقى]
استيقظ
بداية ديسمبر ولا أحد ما زلت
الفئران
العمل عن قصد لأنه ولكن
مصدر رئيسي جدا هو نعم و
تلاحظ ديروتون المتخلفة أقل
مساعدة لا سي جيه بهم فالي وميداس
ليس لدي مثل هذه الأخبار
الوصي عليموف وغيرها عجب البنات الساخنة
ايرون بيلز لي يو مناجم فيلم واحد
مجهول
صباح الخير الجميع باداييف لحظة azil
ريما الأرشيف إيرين عاهرهم
كسب dallmayr أشعر أنني بحالة جيدة
أنا نفسي عزلت المحاور التي أملكها
القدرة على التواصل من خلال
الشرفة هنا شرفة بلدي وليس هناك
الزوج يجلب الطعام على كرسي مرتفع
يسلب حالتي الطبيعية
أنا فقط لا أستطيع ولكن رأسي يؤلمني
انسداد الأنف قليلا ، أنا على قيد الحياة و
عمليا صحية اليوم
قبل الجميع للحظة